i'm going to read the first page of
california christmas and as a
cinematographer maybe you can interject
and
tell me what you think of different
parts that i'm reading
exterior northern california skyline
morning
in a soft glide through a cluster of
clouds we ascend above multiple wine
vineyards and rolling hills until san
francisco's skyline emerges in front of
us so i knew as soon as i read that that
was stock footage i mean i knew the
scope
of our of our film and and
i knew that our only aerial would be
would be with a drone that couldn't get
that kind of altitude and distance
and the funny thing is is is
more than a few people have have emailed
me and their
compliment is oh my god i just loved
those aerial shots of san francisco and
the bay bridge and i'm like well thank
you i will pass those compliments along
to the stock footage company
which you know they always take in good
humor but um
but yeah
funny anecdote they wondered how you got
those
those they i don't think they wondered
they trusted but i had i had to
i had to tell them that well that's the
dream but it's only a dream
because you would have had to do it with
i mean would have been a helicopter a
helicopter right a drone
at that altitude
a drone won't rise to that altitude and
you couldn't get that kind of distance
with it
you know it's not going to fly into the
over the bay and into the city right
okay yeah because that's have you been
on that bridge did you drive over that
i'm sure i've been to san francisco many
times but i don't specifically
someone is afraid of heights okay well
in a car i don't i only care when
there's nothing between me and and the
and the drop if i'm in a car or a
helicopter i don't you know even if
there's a high railing i'm fine we soar
over the golden gate bridge until we
arrive at an upscale building
interior van aston hotel suite bedroom
morning
sunlight pours into a beautiful
high-rise hotel suite as joseph van
aston 25 attractive with egotistical
confidence enters the bedroom from the
bathroom wearing only a towel so so when
i i i heard that i mean i felt it was a
penthouse
kind of thing which which would have
been challenging because you know when
it's a when it's a penthouse i mean
unless you've got the money to to you
know lower a scaffold outside the the
building you can't light from outside um
fortunately we we landed in in this
really cool um structure which was part
of a hotel it was a it was a banquet
area in a hotel that we treated as a
bedroom and it was not only was it not
a high level it was actually
slightly submerged but there was this
really nice high window that you
actually see in the movie
and um
that was you know i have these wonderful
lights called m18s which are uh
these lovely hmis i mean they're just
such a go-to hmi and and i i put one out
the window and um that was a scene we
didn't have a lot of time for because
they wanted us out of the hotel we we
had somewhere else to be originally i
was going to do two hmis out that window
and we just didn't have time we just we
just did the one and fortunately it
works perfectly i mean looking at it i
am like i don't even know why i would
have wanted the second one and really i
would have used it to create more depth
but the director didn't want the the
camera there anyway so
it all just worked out fine but uh yeah
i put that i put that light in there and
it was you know pretty hot and spicy and
i was a little bit worried that maybe it
was too hot
we modulated it some
and you know then in the end i've had
some people say that that's one of their
favorite scenes
he throws open the closet door walks in
interior van assen hotel suite walk-in
closet morning joseph grabs an expensive
suit off of the rack and rips the tags
off of it the towel drops to the ground
around his feet when i heard that i
figured you know
um closet we're probably gonna have to
build
a little piece of a set
because you know any real closet you're
not gonna get the camera far enough away
from him to get behind
the the clothes i guess if you had a big
walk-in you could pull back and just
set some clothes in the foreground
um
but for whatever reason i was thinking
that you know we would have to build
that and and as it worked out again it
was a banquet room and that door that he
goes through is actually it just goes
back to a prep area where are there all
these trays and and um you know metal
things and and and racks and crap and we
just cleared out a space and and we shot
a little corner but it's actually a
really big big like if you turned around
there's just you know tons of room
filled up with junk um and then we you
know we pulled the camera back and and
we stole one of the wardrobe
department's rolling um you know uh
wardrobe hangers and we just stuck it in
there and uh but again we had to shoot
it really really quick and that was one
of those things where like with his feet
and the uh
the uh
towel dropping i mean literally i was
just trying to get it in place and like
roll roll roll oh my god you know
so we didn't get a i mean the shot looks
fine but i didn't get to finesse it it
was just kind of like whatever the
lighting was by the time i got the
camera down there because they're like
shoot it let's get out of here we gotta
go
interior van aston hotel suite bedroom
morning joseph steps out of the closet
fully dressed in his suit he looks
fantastic
then looks at his phone with a cringe
insert phone gemma three missed calls
i think they ended up cutting that out i
don't think they've got the gemma stuff
oh i see okay all right well
no i'm just saying i i don't i don't
even know if i don't even remember if we
shot that
okay
trying to remember i thought he had some
kind of a phone but well he has it when
he talks to his mom
but does he have it in this scene maybe
he does
oh i'm not sure because he's dealing
with this this gal that's in his bed
yeah i knew a chunk of this scene was
cut out and i'm trying to remember which
piece it was i think it was the stuff in
the closet it's either cut out or it's
truncated
oh okay well here we have
jasmine oc in a sing-song voice joey
joseph looks up from his phone to the
bed there is the gorgeous jasmine 20s
naked in the bed just waking up before
she can speak joseph grabs a room
service menu and brings it over to the
bed i remember i remember when i read
that i was like what's this naked stuff
because i think it's a christmas movie i
don't know
it's california
well you know lauren wrote it and i
think that girl is a friend of theirs so
i who knows but i mean she was wearing a
what do you call it a camisole
uh so she wasn't naked okay
but you know that was that was that was
funny i remember i remember thinking oh
my gosh you know because anytime you do
nudity it's like there's some
sensitivity and clear the set and and
that's all good but it slows things down
you know because you have to clear the
set and i'm just thinking well that's
gonna complicate stuff but you know in
the end like i said i think she had a
camisole on and we just did the
you know the blanket in a
quasi-suggestive way and and and there
you go and i think that you know i
really like the way that that that sun
looks the the the light looks and it's
it's so funny because i think when i
really get it right you know it feels
like i didn't do it and i'm just looking
at it going wow that looks cool i wonder
who did that you know i don't i don't
feel the ownership of it when it when it
really just
you know goes straight down the track
like that and and you know the flare in
his in his face which is a little
of a stylistic non-sequitur because i
don't think we have a lot of other
flares but it just worked so well in
that scene and it was so beautiful and
and maybe if i'm being honest it's a
tiny bit gratuitous but i think
everybody liked it and i think it's
pretty so there you go
joseph handing the menu breakfast
breakfast is on me checkouts at noon
she grabs the lapel of the suit jacket
and holds him close joseph denies her
kiss with a smile he hovers
to say i have to say he played that so
much better than i pictured it in my
mind
i just love the way he played that scene
and
but the coverage and
it really turned out a lot the way i
pictured it in my mind when i read it i
mean i felt that it really
you know because things don't always do
that i mean sometimes you you picture it
one way and then you get there and the
location is different or the actors play
it different or the act you know the
director wants to cover it different and
it's not quite what you picture but i
that that scene really did play out kind
of the way that i imagined you know
apart from the fact that that his
the way he did that that kiss avoidance
was just so so much better than what i
imagined it would be
right and she says joseph continued soft
i'll call you
jasmine makes a pouty face
and i think
if i remember correctly she says no you
won't yep
yeah that was perfect yeah
okay
that was an interesting it was an
interesting way to to introduce joseph
and it was it was wonderfully succinct i
mean you you set a lot
you set a lot in that that little tiny
scene just to set up what kind of a
playboy and cad he was
and and i think that that made his um
transition more meaningful you know when
you saw that he actually
was falling in love with this
you know tough country girl
right who came from two separate worlds
you know he was used to always hearing
yes she was probably always used to
hearing no she wasn't taking any [ __ ]
from him